hello everybody my name is severins
and i am a professor of bioprocessing
at keck graduate institute in southern
california
we are a center focused on
training for bio processing and
manufacturing industry
so i have been at keck for
almost a year before that i was at an
engineering company integrated project
services
ips one of the top engineering firms
supporting the life science industries
for
facility labs office and anything
related to
manufacturing operations and i spent
over 20 years at merck in a variety of
different roles
working primarily in manufacturing
supporting both full-scale
and pilot-scale manufacture for clinical
lots
and focused on biologics
and vaccines towards the end of my
career although i did start in small
molecule space
so i want to talk today about
collaborating as we build our
new talent pools moving forward and i
think this is really important
and is the reason that i have shifted
from the
industry career over to the academics
at this point in my in my career so
the agenda for today i wanted to talk
through
overview at a high level my perspective
on the definition of biopharmaceutical
manufacturing
so that we're sharing the same
perspective there
projections around the talent pools
because i think that's a key point for
understanding
some challenges that are about to come
to our industry over the next
probably decade or so and then to talk
about farmer 4.0 because another thing
that's going to have a major impact
on our industry is going to be the
digitalization
of our tools and our processes and we
need a talent pool that's ready for that
and so i would talk about what that has
an impact on from a talent point of view
and then some opportunities around
talent development where we can work
together
between academia and industry to build a
better
stronger talent pool for the industry
overall
so in terms of learning outcomes for
today
i hope that by the end of our
presentation that you'll understand the
current state of talent availability in
biopharmaceutical manufacturing
that you'd be able to define the
requirements of pharma 4.0
and the impact it has on the demand for
talent
and then recognizing that we need a
shift in education and training
if we're going to bridge across to
success in this digitized
manufacturing environment that we're
headed towards
just a little bit of an introduction to
what keck graduate institute is
we are a college that is part of the
claremont
colleges consortium which is in
claremont california the easternmost
city in la county and we are a young
institute founded in the 90s with the
mission of translating science for the
benefit of society
there was a recognized gap in bringing
the
scientific discoveries to patients and
the institute was founded with the idea
of working
collaboratively with industry to bring
that ability to bring these these great
life-saving opportunities to patients so
we have three schools
we have the rig school which is focused
on business and
engineering we have a pharmacy school
which offers not only a pharmd
but genetics and occupational therapy is
a program we're kicking off in the next
year
our pharmd for reference doesn't focus
on
retail pharmacies but rather focuses on
where do we place pharmd
in industry recognizing again the role
that they bring to successful
translation of science into commercial
therapeutics
and then we're looking at building a
school of medicine in the next three to
five years we expect to have
a md program and we also are looking at
a physician assistant program as well we
are focused on
an entrepreneurial culture we want our
students to know how to solve problems
and
how to bring things as i said to the
market as successfully and make sure
that patients have access
to all the therapies that are out there
within the
rig school is our center the amgen
bioprocessing center
which was founded with a grant from
amgen in 2003
and we're focused on instruction and
research in
all kinds of biopharmaceutical
processing including mammalian and
microbial
cell culture and fermentation stem cell
research
bioseparations and purification and
we're building a stronger and stronger
set of tools in data analytics
so overall biopharmaceutical processing
and where it is today
we really are in a place where things
are changing
significantly so there is this
concept of three pillars of medicine you
can see the the graphic here
and you know we started with molecular
therapies 150 years ago
and have grown through monoclonal
antibodies largest
molecules in that space into gene
therapies
and cellular therapies where we're
trying to either bring
a gene and correct that genetic material
so we achieve the therapeutic benefit or
where we're actually trying to change
cells whether in vivo or in vitro to
affect an improved therapeutic outcome
so i want to shift then to think about
what do we
need as talent to support that broad set
of modalities that's coming down the
pipeline
so when we talk to executives around the
world
um and ask what are the biggest
challenges the
constraints and talent are a large piece
of that uh
challenge for the future and you can see
that um
when hiring managers talk about who
they're looking for
they're looking for positions outside of
r d
that translation space how do we bring
this product
from the lab and into the therapeutic
area so the most challenging
areas to fill are in this bioprocessing
space
so regulatory affairs process
development quality
and you can see this comes from a over
arching survey that was done by the
coalition of state biosciences institute
and
in addition um we have a constraint not
just on
what our our talent is capable of
but how much talent we have so right now
we're about
to head down into a constraint on talent
just driven
out of demographics so you can see here
that what's shown is the population of
18 year olds
in any given year and you can see that
as of 2021 we'll be at the lowest point
in a long time for the number of 18 year
olds which of course is the feed
into our undergraduate universities and
they feed into our
stem talent pool it does grow over the
course of the next few years but then it
looks to plummet radically so
when thinking about how to address the
problems of talent it's not just a
question of what they do
but how many we have and how efficient
are we in addition um
until recently we had very low
unemployment
and obviously the impact of the
coronavirus
on our overall economy is still yet to
be defined
but there is still
a large competition for the limited
amount of talent we have
and hopefully once our countries are all
back
up and running again we will see again
that
opportunity for full employment which
therefore often reduces the drivers for
higher education so
oftentimes we see in these times of high
employment
that students don't pursue those higher
level degrees that are there and are
required for the scientific and
technical
aspects of our industry and then i
talked a little bit about how our
industry is changing
and how the technical requirements
around the industry are changing so
not only are there more and more
technology platforms related to the
different
types of products but there's more
technology for how we make each product
and there's more need to cross those
platforms with each other and that
multi-disciplinary focus is getting
more and more important
so what's it look like going forward
into the future
so when asked the biggest challenge for
the growth of the industry you can see
there's a number of items that are
listed but the second
item listed by executives around the
world
is the staff and technically trained
staff so
where are we going to get that
technically trained staff it's changing
then who it is
and who that staff is so the
workforce is going to be more and more
diverse and you can see
um these are a couple of graphics from a
great report from deloitte on the
biopharma workforce
and you can see that we'll be looking
for
people with different sets of skills as
well as different
kinds of people and people will be
contributing to our industry
from different avenues so we won't be
having
everybody be a full-time employee who
shows up to the manufacturing side every
day we have to learn how
to reach out and work with employees who
are around the globe
in different places at different times
and contributing what their skills
can bring to our new digital
environments
so that's a little bit about the talent
constraints and and where we might be
headed
so where's the industry going so what
you hear in a lot of
conversations is talking about pharma
4.0
so in introducing pharma 4.0 it's good
to start with
what's this concept of 4.0 so what is
manufacturing 4.0 so
you can see the concept comes out of a
uh
it was actually a german article i think
that coined the terms that the the first
generation of industrial resolute
revolutions was
really um water and steam power when
when machines were able to be operated
beyond human power and then the second
industrial revolution
is aligned to mass production the
assembly line
and the wide availability of electricity
and kind of the early um
to 1900s and then somewhere in the 1970s
1980s computers and automation became
more and more important
for all of our industries and we started
to be able to
tell our machines and equipment what to
do through computers
this fourth generation which is what we
talk about when we're focusing on
manufacturing 4.0
is the cyber physical systems talking to
each other
so rather than humans driving through
automated computer systems
the automation will talk to other
automation and
gather information in order to drive
things forward
so in discussing that there's a few
points that are important
one is the the idea of cyber physical
systems or cps
so overarching the 4.0 is really the
delivery of this concept where your
physical plant your supply chain your
shipment
your raw materials the handling all gets
mapped into a virtual environment and
therefore can be manipulated and
operated on by
other virtual systems and it's the full
digitalization
that gives us this opportunity for 4.0
manufacturing
in addition you have the integration of
the internet of things
so we're integrating technology and
sensors
that are speaking wirelessly across
different pieces of equipment
and systems and that allows us using
analytical tools to make real-time
decisions and that's
really the benefit is that we have a
constant feedback loop inside
our overall manufacturing process so to
ensure that we're constantly delivering
the most efficient that we can
and then finally the digital
transformation
impacts everything that we do it's not a
digital transformation
that is talking just about your
manufacturing environment
or robots operating your packaging line
it's talking about
being able to manage your data through
your supply chain and through your
shipment channels as well
so from raw materials to customers a way
to think of it
so here's a great depiction from uh
tony mary's toulouse at astrazeneca
um thinking about how does this impact
us in the pharmaceutical industry
so how we work today we really have
um a lot of different steps that are
still
very manual even in our most
in our most automated facilities and
you can see starting at number one that
we have
paper batch records in a lot of places
still we're getting
more and more to electronic batch
records but we still have a lot of
paper log books calibration records um
all kinds of things that are paper and
because they're paper we don't have
real-time data so we can't make
real-time decisions
and in addition we still have a lot of
manual
and repetitive work and that limits how
efficient we can be
and anytime we continue to rely on
manual steps
we of course increase human error
anytime we have humans we have error
so what we're looking for um is going to
move us out of that space
in addition the supply chain as i
mentioned is the piece of this the
supply
chain visibility is often manual and
we're still relying
on often very
highly evolved spreadsheets but still
spreadsheets
and then we have paper-based
instructions for how to move things
between
and then the lack of visibility in the
movement of our goods we don't know
where things are in the supply chain
where we want to get to in a digitalized
environment
would be to have access to these data so
if we take everything that we just
discussed
and we digitize it we would go from
paper batch records to electronic batch
records that
are not only recording but are
predicting
and enabling us to use analytics as
feedback control to make sure we
constantly stay in the most optimal
space for the best quality product
we would therefore have real-time data
for continuing to manage that process
control as i mentioned
um more and more we could rely
on automated and robotic solutions to
move
physical things forward through our
processes
have the ideal environment where we can
visualize
our end-to-end supply chain and we know
where our product is
at any given time and then looking at
other
wireless solutions um wearable and mo
mobile
type solutions that give us data
without having to think about
translating that data so
imagine somebody is writing with a
a wireless pen we automatically capture
that data
rather than having to transcribe it back
into a computer system later or wearing
a pair of goggles that just
looks at a balance and sees the weights
and records that way directly into our
electronic batch record going forward
so all of this iot and digitalization
brings data real time
to our systems and this is what we call
farmer 4.0
so the impact on our talent pool is
going to be significant
and talking through a little bit of that
um
there's going to be a obviously we've
heard a lot in this
presentation already about that
interconnection of the real and virtual
world
and our people our employees our staff
are going to have to understand
what that means and how they fit into
that part they're always going to be in
the real world
but this virtual world is going to be
existing and operating around them
there's going to be decentralized
intelligence that means it's not all
decisions are getting made on the floor
or by a supervisor or a manager
and so we're going to have all these
object-related
decision making going on and you need to
understand the impact of that the risk
of that and make sure that our systems
are built
to for success in the long term
um autom autonomous process management
is obviously a goal it's something
honestly that's been talked about
since i was in this industry since i
first joined over 30 years ago we've
been talking about
lights out facilities and the
opportunity for our
facilities to run without staff there to
move things forward
and then data management um a
tool that we need to think about is what
do we do with data we get
lots and lots of data but it's not
helpful unless we can move it through an
analysis and take action and only after
we've taken action have we
brought value to the data so thinking
about all of this
and what it means for our talent um
based on a
a report that was
built um again by deloitte and was
presented
uh recently at davos here's some quotes
that i think are
really meaningful there aren't too many
people we can take straight out of
university who have everything we need
so as academics we need to take this
feedback and say
what do we need to be doing because
we're adding
a burden to our customers if they have
to train people
after they leave the academic
environment
the it's hard for business to ask
governments to prepare the students and
i read that as government
and academia because things are changing
so rapidly and the speed by which the
education
system changed is a completely different
track and really the point there
is that academics aren't paying enough
attention to how fast we need to move to
keep up
with our partners and and our customers
and industry
and last the
fact that the focus is on needing more
group-based and project-based activities
because this is how we work
and this is how we'll work more and more
and
i would overlay on top of that that
these need to be virtual group based and
project-based activities
and all of us with our response to
coronavirus are now
seeing how we can work virtually and how
we can still maintain our group
activities and push our project forward
and we need to take ownership of that
and move that forward in the
academic world so another thing to think
about
is a what are the skills that are
required
so we tend to think about skill
requirements and we think about
technical skills i need to teach
somebody how to operate a line i need to
teach somebody what a
cell culture should look like in reality
when we
survey industry participants we find
that
more and more the focus is on softer
skills and on the ability to
step up and deliver new solutions so of
course complex problem solving which
incorporates all those
technical skills stays at the top but
what we see
is that what's increased over the last
five years is critical thinking
and creativity that we really need
people to be evaluating that data
and if you think about this how this
relates to digital organization
that data we need to know that it makes
sense so we need people
thinking critically about every step and
the inputs and then
being creative about how to bring that
together and how to drive towards
solution
and a couple things that are new on the
list for 2020
emotional intelligence because we're
going to be working across so many
different sets of skills
and we need teams to deliver and not
individuals
this becomes more and more critical as
we move forward and harder and harder to
deliver honestly across virtual
platforms
and so we need to focus on building
those skills in that virtual space
and then cognitive flexibility and this
is about
being able to learn new skills this is
meeting that business demand for a
changing environment
and teaching our students not what they
know but how to learn
more how to learn going forward and so
we're not trying to only focus on
content we need to teach students to
teach themselves
how do they get on google and solve a
problem rather than
having a professor teach them so
those are a couple of skills and in the
trade-offs um for those skills
what decreased and fell out of the list
coordinating with others and negotiation
which i think are built into some of
these other activities so they slipped
down a little bit
but they're still important but what
left was uh
quality control and active listening um
but i i would argue that uh
the critical thinking that coordinates
and covers quality control and
emotional intelligence clearly requires
active thinking so i think it's a
broadening of that concept rather than
an elimination
so what does this mean in
detail for our skills that we need for
biopharmaceutical manufacturing how do
we bring that together
so the skills for the pharma 4.0 that we
talked about
have to encompass all the emerging
technologies like continuous
manufacturing salvaging therapy
process analytical technologies in order
to get that ongoing data acquisition
in addition to some of the things that
we've talked about
for years and process understanding
we've been talking about quality by
design and continuous process
verification we need more
understanding and a more
multi-disciplinary
commitment to understanding compliance
and regulatory affairs
and that is going to happen through a
better understanding of data integrity
we need rapid release particularly to
support some of these new modalities
like cell and gene therapy there just
isn't time for 60 day
release turn around windows and
automated
file updates as well so electronic ctd
give us the opportunity
to constantly update our files so that
the agencies understand what we're doing
and make sure that we're not putting
patients at risk around the world
as well as the hopeful opportunity to be
able to roll
out an important change around the world
much more rapidly than we can do now it
can take up to two years to make a
change in our regulatory filing systems
which means we can't get inventory at
the highest level
of quality with our most recent
processes for two years to some of our
patients
and then last we have to bring in a
stronger understanding of data
management
really that inability as i talked about
to go from acquisition and aggregation
to
analysis and action so that we bring
value out of our data
and that data management has to
encompass broader tools
we have to be able to implement the
internet of things the wireless
sensing and as it covers inventory the
instruments on our equipment
the robotics we need that information
constantly flowing
and constantly being transformed into
meaningful information for action
and coupled with that is going to be
artificial intelligence
as well as machine learning and
real-time feedback
so you can see all of these things and
these are the technical skills and how
they
they deliver for pharma 4.0 and we think
about that when we think about
building the capabilities of our new
talent
a little bit more about um the
employment requirements so
beyond the technical skills as i
mentioned there's a
focus on the soft skills and
the drive for multi-disciplinary
knowledge is just
getting stronger and stronger because we
have to be able to communicate with each
other
it doesn't mean that somebody who is a
scientist
needs to therefore understand the
details of software
development for robotics but it does
need to be
that they're aware enough of those
robotics and their uses that they can
explain
what they can get out of it and what
their requirements are from a scientific
point of view
so it's building those engagement and
that multi-disciplinary conversation
that's going to drive the most
successful companies
we need to integrate quality and
regulatory into our operations they
can't be
a secondary thing they need to be a part
of the operations
and therefore all our employees
staff as well have to be able to
understand their quality and regulatory
environments
and then business and financial
operations we're making decisions on the
floor
every day that have business and
financial impact and
if we don't train our staff to
understand those
we will be as successful as we could be
what pharma 4.0 brings to us is the
opportunity for higher level operations
and oversight
but what it means in terms of
implementation
we will be starting with task-based
automation so we automate
certain tasks and then we build that
together to get to that higher level
oversight
and part of that has to be the data
interpretation and response
and understanding how to bring those
models
to give us the the input and the
process controls that we're looking for
rapid reskilling as i mentioned that our
talent
our skills have to be developed over and
over and over again
there's been major shifts every 10 years
in this
environment and i think they're getting
faster so
you can imagine 10 years ago we didn't
have discussions around crispr gene
therapy car t mrna the
microbiome was just coming out as a
a treatment platform it's amazing how
fast things change in a decade
and yet we come into this field and we
contribute four to five decades which
means we have to be relearning
four to five times at least and maybe
more
as things tool faster and faster and
then
the critical and soft skills that we
really need to focus on
um innovation and teamwork and managing
our resources to make sure
everybody is efficiently delivering
towards the value of
our organization so
if those are all the requirements and
these are the pressures on our industry
as we get towards 4.0
what are our opportunities for talent
development
and as an academic institution we're
looking
out into our business world and to our
partners to better understand
what do we need to be delivering for
talent capabilities
so one of the considerations um
for employee development there's a broad
set of things to think about when you
when you think about how to develop an
employee to be
uh aligned to the value they need to
bring to your business
and this is a model developed by
um the uh the labor and statistics
board of united states and you can see
what it does is bucket things into two
dimensions
so we have the horizontal dimension that
looks at things that are occupational
specific on the right those skill sets
that
apply to your given occupation and then
things that are important across
occupations
um you can see to the left and then you
have the vertical
where we have things that are at the top
focused on the worker
as an individual and things at the
bottom that are focused on the job
and so in the middle is obviously what
we deliver as a full employee
so where we can deliver as an academic
institution
is really looking at worker requirements
and experience requirements and this is
the space
that we're really trying to focus on
understanding
and looking for collaboration with
industry
to build so if you think about
educational opportunities in a kind of
uh pyramid shape as a lot of things
are you can say that the top of the
pyramid
is the elite research and undergraduate
universities
and you can quickly come up with a list
of these universities these are the ones
you think of and you hear about
all the time on the news and in research
platforms and
there's a secondary level that's also
very active all of these provide
very strong training opportunities and
excellent uh capabilities for academic
skills development
at the bottom of our pyramid is
the development um lower cost kind of
opportunities for
um career prep and workforce development
so our staff
that are coming in and working
on the floor as opposed to being in the
research labs
and we're looking at how do we develop
that
broad base of support from an operations
point of view
and there's there's programs that are
focused on that for our industry for
bioprocessing
delaware as a program at the university
of delaware
the delaware biotechnology institute wpi
is a program our north carolina state
has a program jefferson has a program
and they're working on making sure that
our workforce
that's already in the corporate
environment
is is getting prepared and is continuing
to be developed
there's a place in the middle
that we work on at thinking about
how do we collaborate industry and
with academia to develop talent
that comes out as a little bit more
prepared than undergraduates
but isn't quite yet in the workforce and
isn't part of these other workforce
development activities
and that's an area that we really focus
on at kgi
so the uh we partner with nimble and
bpog as
inputs these are consortiums in the
industry uh
nimble is a us-based government
supported
part of the department of commerce uh
it's
established to generate opportunities
for technology and workforce development
in biomanufacturing and bpog is
bio forums operations group is based out
of
england and is a worldwide global
organization focused on
mostly technology platforms but tackling
the need for
developing capabilities across the
industry
so where does that lead us to the future
of work
so we need leaders who understand the
business value of data analytics and are
going to drive the implementation of
these digital solutions
and we need then management to work
across the supply chain
for efficient solutions and support new
work models
that attract and retrain and retain the
key talent
and then we need that talent to
continuously build new skills
so bringing all of that together with
our educational opportunities
and the idea of how do we develop an
employee we have developed this map
of how to build an industry
collaborative
opportunity for talent development
so we start with rigorous course
offerings
focused in depth and as well on emerging
topics as well as
the 50 year old understanding of
heat and mass transfer that are
necessary in our industry
industry participation we want
our industry partners to be part of our
lectures to be
providing guest lectures to do on-site
training
to bring us current tools we also work
for
hands-on experience not only in our labs
which of course are part of our course
offerings but
we want our students to do internships
and to do corporate sponsored projects
so they understand what it's like to
work
in your environments when they leave so
that we meet that need of
when a student comes out of our program
they're ready to contribute to the day
they walk out of the program
and we hope that this drives us to a
talent pool
that at the entry level is incredibly
strong
that allows the or they understand the
business they're getting in so the
retention is high
their innovative employees who are able
to see the global impact of their work
and in conclusion i'm just revisiting um
the pharma 4.0 is really changing the
requirements for the talent pool in our
industry
and we have to address that both through
ongoing programs
for existing employees as well as
through an
understanding and investment in the
academic opportunities that we
offer to students we need to
sustain a strong talent pool with
multi-disciplinary training
and then we strongly recommend that we
work together
across academics and industry to bring
these opportunities to support the
growth of our industry into the future
and i appreciate your attention i
understand that
questions will be forwarded through
email so i appreciate your
questions and look forward to more
collaboration into the future
thank you